can yo get the bunny ball inside from
yogic to Millsap but in the league last
year he's getting double-teamed pick up
games this summer and he didn't like it
now Murray back out to Yogesh and the
pass
somehow gets to Porter who dunks it once
Michael Porter this ball how he gets it
to guys just converged nice pass what a
drawn dish by yoga choice this guy is so
good they're the two front liners
the basket Millsaps challenges and just
a long outlet by the Joker here we go
they will probably sent somebody dump it
under Murray with a great weak side cut
the okage for the cutter he's got burned
[Applause]
Jamal Murray
- warming up look out okay no sad
hesitation that open things up me from
the field Paris behind the back yogic
dribble-drive
sets up Gary Harris beautiful from the
corner it's a beautiful thing folks
[Applause]
it spins it right here my card in the
bigs and then oh looks at de Martin who
gets the Antoine he's dribble like this
my more guys don't get into the paint
like anything we'll look at him he knows
where he is hero comes over I made the
three a while ago
once it's just backdoor off the concrete
so hero way up high and just ended
that's a good pass break it with us on
altitude Nuggets leading six top yoga
Chazz it he's got Harris on the leg and
State Department
is good time Billy I'm so my part but
she's looking for Gary ends up by Barton
on the far wing lay up and dipper
another fast break point lead by three
yo kids Department
quarter watch his back door that was
what we'll cut with the will part was
dil Jeff King a very good player played
with Millsaps that mid-roll how it's
open for Juncker but it looks like it's
were open for other people as well
so pretty he sees him
the Reid Sadler once again see how the
weak side goes asleep and you just get a
cutter weak side goes to sleep the
smallest guy on the floor he cuts the
basket gets a layup we're all looking
for Plumlee to give the Nuggets a spurt
of energy nice pass and Murray girls it
brought a pass just to the past one
right there in the bank receipt by
getting the ball below the free-throw
line in that painted area look at the
bodies for blue shirts and now that
kick-out for Paul Millsap would be it
when the ball is dead joking
[Applause]
kick it out the three backdoor poke
timber a nice little run the starters
are back in and there gets it going to
yo kids coming inside Park fires
[Applause]
see if the Nuggets keep it up for the
last four minutes here's got back
touched buries in the lane
- for Denver here spot summation that
stops 813 nothing wrong Marcus smart way
downtown
we depart
when I paid for three fun fire nine too
early good guys
watch oh and grand ready to come in he
got a finish to that word right there it
gets away with it then lock up on the I
think no food three they're second in
the way the first place Lakers had a
nice reverse by Paul Millsap
[Applause]
you're throwing it down Nicoli okage
finding Michael Porter Jr Nicole Jochen
cut by Gary Harris who lays it in and
the assistant Nicola oaken's the lead is
nine down the Myrtle Marie who drops it
home no Jamal Murray starting to score
he's up to 11 points second nugget in
double figures Yogesh as you look at the
3-point story back cut Harris floater
cool now long range for Kentavious
caldwell-pope off the running the other
side see watch it gets ahead of every
season bunch of wives you just kind of
get control of it and making sure it
gets over the front of rim that's the
dotted line that time weak side didn't
see it back caught beautiful pass on the
bounce from Nicola okage the two points
for Monta Morris it's with a two
Vantage will pitch spins you got a
wide-open Millsap who grills it the cold
knew right where he was going it's
nothing al and Bernie back to yo kitch
popping out the bill set for three got
eggs Paul Millsap who is fourth in the
NBA in three-point percentage much more
engaged in the second half 15 first
corner points pardon on the board for
the first time since he's got 18 now
Bert has nine in the corner but a big
pick up he will be for Philadelphia
especially come playoff time
nice leave by yo kids Laurie Craig
cutting to the basket with the layup see
him get one to go here the start of the
second half Murray inside with the leap
the tips in the juice puts it off any a
nice feed from on top - it's 15 and 8
their record after the big win Thursday
night
by Jamal Murray
they look different without Westbrook
without Paul George just dump it down
the middle of Bart's six points all
three layups and do those assisted by
Nicola you're gonna bother
cp3 nobody better straight to let it go
[Music]
guts it in another assist were Nicole
the Yogesh that'd be seven Torrey Craig
snap it over the bird into Portland SEO
kitsch they went five and six without
him but they're glad to have him back
because he is one of the six pieces
Jamal Murray here he's shooting just 42%
his lowest in his six seasons thirty
from the three yeah he's really been
strung to another back
[Applause]
yo kitsch on the bounce - will the
thrill' Michael carter-williams who's
coming
throws it down period just how very very
good pass-down
most of those I would say have come from
a debate Yogesh
all of those things that Saunders may be
the youngest coach but basketballs in
his blood he's ducks perfect pass by yo
kids it looked like the t-wolves were a
1 to 2 so here's what you're talking
about that one too - Marlo - Joker's
driving a gap there and then drawing the
defense up Jamal Murray sneaking into
the opening inside the land an easy pass
to an easy
Marie Yogesh oh great look and pass till
will Bart he had the 15-footer but a
two-footer is bent points got the shot
right here everybody just turns his head
in the wrong direction
blueberry went Rip Van Winkle on that
one a Spartan beat him to the punch
best play of class while they look good
we go backdoor Booker had a scoreless
first half and remember he's their
leading scorer at 24 and a half points
per game slide it under to Murray great
pass by yogic and time out money
Williams a couple assists already in
this quarter to an 82 man candy real
like Seabury get going get back to that
on cue Murray with a dunk
[Applause]
now that was coming out of the break
designed play ran perfect and you're
right guy yet guys going Malone is
wondering whether to challenge this
signal here shall insist
this will be him pushing underneath same
official there's that little fact or put
and it's as high up as I've ever seen
morale in that connect their bow Jones
although it was worrying initiated
contractors for two points in these four
minutes
[Applause]
and it'll shoot a free throw or 13 off
the bench 13 really turns the corner to
get to order for free
[Applause]
as by Nicola yoga did all the bodies and
they're worried about juggler the ball
just no looks integrand instead of
standing out somewhere else
once you got Jackson watching Joker so
he's just attacks the basket Nuggets 22
and 9 on to their best start in Nuggets
franchise history down the middle before
he drops it all switched it off on [ __ ]
yo ketchup and under her and steak the
Millsap who drops it in Millsap who
listen not taking away the paint not
taking away the threes committing way
too many turnovers Murray for three
that's a good summary drops one in
nope it's coming in convincin Millsap
puts it away chorus one to shoot floated
up tip no yo Kitsch has it sling it out
to Barton for three good here's a couple
of the passes first the rebound stays
with it watch some he just fires that
from inside he's trying to get more
separation
yo catches bid the man get 37 and Barton
is inside for the land
yo kitch had a huge first quarter a
couple of nights ago in that win against
Atlanta makes a great pass there the
Harris who's got four points to
one-on-one again against Powell they got
the whole side cleared out and he passes
it off to Cory Craig the layup
[Applause]
no Torrey Craig is in the grand
watch as he goes to the middle
grant just moves defender helps out he
just goes the basket filled that empty
spot and especially in the paint that
that in the lane 94 feet doing a pretty
good job of it so far
[Applause]
Gretchen and Murray scores seven
straight points got seven assists on 7
May whew
I'm 20 and that's children just trying
to play hurry
[Applause]
for points again for the Pistons Golden
State nice feed inside yogic with a
cutter into the defense reporter with a
three from outside this young man is
want to be good
[Applause]
just never know what's gonna happen
Jory Craig not only does he block and
Christmas saves it at the am which was
big then watch his past he just drops it
off to Tory you have to be ready for the
ball move past that often attack the
defense when they have the numbers
squeegees it up and in
16 points as yoke it sets up grant and
Jeremy grant has 10 first quarter points
yeah offensively here Jeremy grant see
is that Karl Anthony towns doesn't step
up all the way good play Jeremy grant
it's for 206 the middle man give it to
pray and he scores again
too early you got attack Houston they're
good offensive demon don't give up
supports at the rim
inside got it
nice play the nuggets habit and trailing
by one here under to Gary Harris great
and catch was gonna ask that's just a
great bastion that's Joker you get feet
on the 101 comes over to help the tribe
but no one helps him on the rebound for
a second chance point for the pelicans
double nuggets had six and Torrey Craig
lights up another three ball Pepsi
Center doing a great job with a
retrospective on Kobe and then a moment
of silence my presence and everything
[Applause]
Kolia coach is he talking how much does
he enjoy playing with joker oh it's
unbelievable you know he said he's a dad
anytime you cut and move no matter where
you were you cutting and moving he will
find you so I'm like dude just cut and
move and Craig out of trouble to Jeremy
grant
Big Shot difference guys start playing
fast too when he made the bucket and got
the call well I think he's stand out
more Brooks because Brooks is saying I
didn't do anything and you seemed slap
his arm right there shot clock down to
ten what does Yogi's do here wants to
take over defensive team in the league
the first in defensive efficiency down
to : they swarm him pass underneath
great look once hits one too you see
Middleton came over and just left me
coming over from the Lakers in a trade
for a second-round pick shooting the
right here it takes in Temple City sees
Tory have Lex Peters gets a little late
that's thrown into double coverage Snell
42% from three so that's not a big
surprise their backside is beautiful and
barton puts it away for this team and
watch this nice little fake high go low
scope gets over the top seven our scores
hump it down department and both leaves
his ways good shot
and a nice back and this large a big guy
that could just roll and stay in front
of Ram
[Applause]
as he gets his first bucket in the
return moorlands on a seven to run
against the small dump don't ladies
listening motivated there to jump high
sit off the bench already with 19 points
back cut nice cut and a good bucket for
Denver
right here yoku just had the hot hand
see it everybody eat his weights EZ Pass
head fake lay it up you're under man
different legate's they've got marbles
layer playing well tonight it's 17 and 9
Millsap 12 off the bench tonight
mojo Creek in and saw grant puts it away
with authority
[Applause]
yo gets the assist Rick Adelman who will
be in the Hall of Fame one day as a
coach one of the most brilliant
offensive minds we've ever had inside
getting the bucket is Morris James body
Murray can't finish at the rent wanted a
foul call didn't get it Harrison
transition able to score Miami Heat what
are the surprises of the season fourth
place in the East
beautiful press yogic with the set up
for Simmons that's been assist away but
yoga CH has been at such a high level
for such an extended period of time
parish lines it up and knocks it down
big three for Gary Harris counters
technical foul here's that pass middle
just cut loose off turn over when we got
his hand and it knocked the ball away
from Joker I pick a roll get to the mill
the floor four guys got too high too low
like they kind of gave him away but they
won this shed salaries Andre Drummond
now a Cleveland Cavaliers
[Applause]
the Nagas strike first like I said
what's the pass I mean they they read it
pretty good but smart buying grant he
knows he bring here okay I can't dunk
let me just try to guide it into the
square and Davis answers back with a
three so it's 45 to 38 delegates with
the beautiful pass that's it's a Bobby
Boucher reference oh look at that pass
right there great over Thomas's head
round the pressure Boucher's got
pressure how your you know your regimen
of throwing of lifting everything he's
been such a big help to me this
offseason my first one to really get me
going knowing piston yo kicks
what's the rebound in the window I mean
that's just over the defendants hand I
mean Larry if flower is an inch tall it
never touched his second hand my Adsit
man it's just that's a crazy past a
chess set and the assistant Accola
Yogesh this for the Denver Nuggets what
a pass right there by Nicola
he's already double figures it's coming
into tonight a 16 point favorite here at
home
Marie in the head right there and he's
able to just concentrate but you wear
those no t-shirts no kitchens only
taking one shot he's gonna lob it into
Millsap who puts it to bed and when the
nuggets are cooking offensively like
they are that's when you got a hunker
down on defense and say we're gonna get
stopped inside to Barton yes messes it
up give it to Millsap for embarrassing
tequila if you sneeze on Millsap you see
Dallas covered off the lost last night
to San Antonio 119 109 as Murray hits
the three to begin things here tonight
for Denver
pocket pass perfectly timed a lot of
space as Morris buries the three Dallas
covered off the loss last night to San
Antonio 119 109 as Murray hits the three
to begin things here tonight for Denver
he sets the tone antenna right like to
start the game they're shooting 63% for
different guys have an assist they're
getting any shot they want there's
another open shot bang a three like
pocket pass perfectly timed a lot of
space as Morris buries the three a
nine-point Dallas lead nice such a nice
pass you know you put
you
[Applause]